[Music]
all right good afternoon everyone bye
good afternoon I of course mean good
morning my name is dr. McPherson like
she said I am a software engineer on the
our Studio IDE and today I'm going to
talk to you about some of the new
language features that we built into our
studio 1.2 before do that though a bit
of background so it's been our
experience that as people work with our
they are often working with more than
one tool at the same time and they're
creating projects that have bits and
pieces that are composed of different
languages for example if you're working
with a our project in our studio you
might need to get some data from a
sequel database and so you need to open
up another window to create a sequel
query and look and look at the data
there so you can analyze it in R and
perhaps by the time you're done with
this query you think of the fine work
that Wes Makena did on pandas and think
maybe you'll use that to analyze the
data
so you open up pycharm and then you
remember that you've actually been asked
to visualize this data in a bubble chart
which you can't think of an R package to
do so you start visualizing that in d3
and then you start thinking about
modeling and you start browsing
Wikipedia for modeling languages like
Stan and you can play that game in
Wikipedia if you ever played that game
where you click on the very first link
of every article and you always wind up
at philosophy every time try it out and
then the next thing you know you're at
the zoo and you are shaving a yak so
this is this will not do so this is the
kind of problem one of the kinds of
problems we are trying to solve with our
studio 1.2 so our goals for us to do a
1.2 are are many but one of them is to
be more comprehensive workbench for your
our projects so we're going to embrace
some of the languages that we commonly
see people use in their our data science
projects and we're gonna make the
interoperability between them those
languages a lot more seamless they are
not doing so much context switching if I
think about that slide that I just
showed with all those windows like every
time you have to switch between tools
switch between windows every time you
have to import data from one tool export
it into another tool that takes a lot of
your time and mental energy and kind of
breaks you out of the state of flow
while you're working under dated a
science project so we're hoping that we
can take some of these workflows
and make them really easy to do
seamlessly right inside of our studio
must have some non goals we don't want
to make one of these things we are not
trying to become a general-purpose IDE
we're not trying to fully replace your
dedicated tools or lose focus on our so
our studio is and always will be first
and foremost workbench for data science
with our so here are the our agenda
we're gonna cover just a few languages
they are as follows sequel Python well
do d3 we'll do you Stan and if we have
time at the end I'm going to show you a
couple of the other fun things we've
added to our studio 1.2 all right so for
most the rest this talk I'm just gonna
do it a live demo of some of these new
language features in our studio and I'm
gonna start with sequel let's look
pretty familiar if you went to the
keynote this morning
so one of the things that we built into
our studio is a data connectivity and
here I'm connecting to a database for a
record store for those of you who still
remember what a record store is so this
database has information about all of
the records that we sell all the artists
who made those records at is information
about customers our employees how much
people have paid for the records etc so
I'm going to start out by creating a
simple sequel query report that tells me
all of the albums that I sell and which
artists created those albums as you can
see this data is currently in separate
tables so I'm gonna start by pressing
this new sequel button you'll see here
and we'll call this albums okay you
notice right away that our studio has
suddenly become an interface it should
be pretty familiar to anyone who has
spent time working on sequel queries you
notice have a list of tables over here I
have a query over here and then I have
the results of the query right here and
it's quite easy for me to work on the
query and to get real-time feedback
about the results of the query here
all right so I just selected from the
artists table as well as you can see
this has a Cartesian join result which
is not all what I want for this query so
I'm going to add a where clause and
you'll notice that as I'm typing I'm
getting real-time out of completion of
the results and of the fields and the
table so I can say where albums and I
can get auto completion there artist ID
equals artists dot artist ID and there
we go so now I've got a quick little
sequel report that tells me all of the
album's that I sell and all the artists
who made the albums again fairly
straightforward but really easy and very
fluid for me to do this without opening
12 windows to look at my schema and my
database of my results the next thing
that we're going to do is we are going
to look at a little notebook that I've
created so this is a notebook that does
a little bit more in-depth analysis it's
gonna help me figure out who the top
customers are at my failing record shop
so I can figure out how I can get more
money out of them to start off with
we're just gonna connect to the sequel
database and I'm gonna use the
reticulate package now a lot of the
things you're about to see are a direct
result of the reticular package this
package doesn't require our studio to
use it was put together by JJ 11 and
Kevin O'Shea and empowers a lot of the
Python interoperability stuff you're
about to see but before we get to the
Python stuff I wanted to note that all
of the really nice things that I just
showed you are not only in the sequel
window they are also available to you
inside of our markdown documents so this
here I have a sequel query and what this
query does is it simply goes out and
gets me a list of every customer and
every invoice that that customer has
ever had
so all that all that nice stuff that I
just showed you is still available right
so I can I can get the same kind of auto
completion that I'm used to and I
actually want to save this query into an
output variable so I can use it later
all right so now I'm going to use the
I'm going to use pandas so I'm going to
use pandas to summarize the data that I
just created so I made a list of
invoices now I'm going to use pandas to
grouped together and summarize that data
to figure out who has spent the most
total money on invoices let's go ahead
and run that and you can see here are my
top five customers now I want to show
you about a couple things that you could
do while you're authoring these chunks
first of all you get the same kind of
audit completion you do in R so just
like you can type library are in R and
you can get a list of your our packages
you can type import them in a Python
chunk you'll get a list of your Python
packages you also get the same kind of
method completion that you get inside of
ours so for instance you could
we've got variables we can see the names
of the functions here if we use a
function we can actually get help for
that function rather than help pain you
can jump to the definition of that
function right in its Python file so we
think that these capabilities make it
really easy for you to very fluidly and
naturally author Python chunks inside of
our marked out or other bits and pieces
of your art project the other thing I'd
like to point out here and some of you
who are a little bit more astute might
have already noticed it is that I didn't
have to do anything to get that data
from sequel into my Python chunk and the
reason is this you'll notice that when I
created an output variable here in
sequel it went into my global
environment right here see here's that
here's that data from sequel and the
only thing I needed to do to reference
that data in Python is this r dot
spinning that just takes the variable
from are called spending and allows me
to use it right inside my pipe my Python
code in previous versions of our studio
and our markdown it was actually
necessary for Python chunks basically
ran in a vacuum like you had to import
the data the beginning of the chunk from
wherever it to save it out the end and
that's no longer necessary reticulate
actually embeds a Python session inside
of your our session so it's very easy
and seamless to get data in in and out
of a Python speaking of getting data in
and out of Python it's also quite easy
to do the op the opposite of what I just
showed you just like you can say r dot
in Python you can say PI dollar sign and
are you notice here I'm getting a nice
real-time out of completion that not
only tells me what data from Python is
available but also gives me some
information about that data so it's here
I can run that chunk and now I've got
the summarized data from Python now
let's do a little bit of visualization
this is something you also kind of saw
hinted at in the keynote I'm gonna use
map pot Lib again right inside of our
studio to visualize these top five
spinners at my my fancy record shop now
another thing that I want you to notice
here is that each one of these Python
chunks is running in the same Python
session and in previous versions you
basically had to run each Python session
independently so every one every one of
these chunks would start a new python
session run all of the code and then
quit all right so now that we have an
embedded session these things can build
on each other you can actually just like
you can with our chunks you can you can
build seamlessly chunk to chunk inside
of inside of your Python chunks so that
the last last chunk in this notebook is
a d3 visualization so it's basically
going to take that same same data I'm
gonna sort by the number of people here
and they're gonna nice little bubble
chart so I want you to notice here that
our studio is not only you know an
environment where you can look at these
d3 visualizations it's also an
environment where you can create them so
you'll notice here that this bubble
chart that I made is a d3 script called
bubble CAS and I can just open that and
start working on that visualization you
notice I've got a preview button here so
I can take a look at what this
visualization looks like and I think
you'll notice that the the font is
really a little bit too small here so
let's go ahead and bump that up you know
us against there's some sample data
appear so that I don't have to have any
actual live data connected with this
thing to work with it
let's go ahead and preview it I can see
the fonts slightly more reasonable and
if I go back here and run my
visualization
I'll see that now my customers names are
a lot easier this
so again very seamless authoring and
integration of d3 visualizations inside
of our studio so now that we've kind of
taken a look at our top five spinners
and spend a little bit of time kind of
passing data back and forth I want you
to like take a step back and think about
what we've just done here we've brought
together sequel and R and Python and d3
into a reproducible publishable report
all without leaving our studio it's
really our hope that it's gonna be very
easy for you to compose these same kinds
of multi-language workflows yourself so
there's a couple other Python features I
wanted to show you really quickly while
we're talking about it Python and that
is mainly that there's a couple of
things that you can do in Python that
are only possible in Python scripts so
you'll notice here I have a new source
script button this just runs that same
code that we looked at earlier that
analyzes my top five spenders however
it's not only possible for me to run the
whole script at once but just like you
can in R you can run the script one line
at a time and you'll notice that when I
do that our studio automatically
switches to an embedded Python console
and this is also powered by the
reticular package and it uses that same
embedded arse sorry that same embedded
Python session that the chunks were
using so all of my state is still here
and it's very easy for me to iterate on
it and I can you know type my own Python
code if I want to and there we go
alright so the only language we haven't
talked about is stand I'm not going to
spend a whole lot of time on it but for
those of you who have worked with Stan
we've now made to stand quite a lot
easier to work with we've got a very
dedicated editor mode for it now we have
all the same things that I just showed
you with respect to Python and sequel
you also will get in stand so but you
have Auto completion and see here I get
a list of all the functions I can call
you'll notice I've already created a
syntax error which is right there
and we also have a document outline that
will show it that makes it really easy
for you to navigate your your stand code
a modest and expert so I'm not gonna
spend a lot more time on this but we
hope this makes it a lot easier for you
to work with stand projects inside of
the IDE
alright so whether or last five minutes
or so I want to show you a couple of
other small features we've added to our
studio 1.2 so the first of these is
background jobs so it's it's been our
experience that when people work with
our they will often create our scripts
that really take quite a lot of time to
run and if you've ever had to work with
these inside of our studio you know that
you basically have to run run the script
and then wait because you can't do a
whole lot of things with our studio
while the our session is busy if you're
on our studio desktop you can launch
another copy of our studio to get some
other possibly unrelated work done but
it can be quite challenging if you if
you want to run a couple of these things
so a background job is basically just
running an R script or something like it
inside a background are our tasks so if
we got a new button here called sources
local job and that's just gonna take the
script that I wrote that I wrote and run
it in the background and get me some
results and I'm done I'm gonna copy the
results to the global environment and go
ahead and start the job you'll notice
here that I get progress and output for
the job as it runs I've got a list of
running jobs over here I can monitor
them on the console and while the job is
running all of them all of the things
that our studio does are still available
right so the our session is not busy and
I'm able to continue to do work while I
run these background processes you're
not limited to just one job you can run
multiple jobs at once it is possible to
run as many jobs as your machine has the
capacity for so hopefully this will make
it a lot easier for you to take those
long-running computations and make them
work really nicely without again having
to constantly switch contexts the the
next little thing that I wanted to show
is Auto installation of missing our
packages so again this is another like
kind of quality of life improvement that
we've made and we've noticed when people
open up an our script that they
themselves wrote a long time ago or from
a
a co-worker and they don't have the
right packages and installed it's kind
of a pain like you have to go manually
find the packages that are missing and
manually install them it sometimes takes
a couple of times to run the script to
figure out which packages you actually
need so in our studio 1.2 we have
created a code parser that basically
analyzes your code to figure out what
packages are going to need in order to
run the script and then gives you a
little prompt that tell that offers to
install those packages for you you'll
notice here that I have asked to run an
our script that uses the carrot package
and the ml binge package because I don't
actually have those packages installed
it's going to actually offer to install
them for me one other little quality of
life improvement that we've added is the
ability to create PowerPoint
presentations I'm not going to spend a
whole lot of time on this but a lot of
people just for purposes of you know
getting they're getting their workflow
done like that there there are stuff
winds up in a PowerPoint presentation so
you can now make those very easily it's
just as easy as making a Word document
without with our markdown and finally I
wanted to show you the appearances pane
here so we've also made it really easy
to change our studio's colors this is
another like small quality of life
improvement that people been asking us
for for many years and it basically
makes it possible for you to add or
remove your own custom themes you can
make these themes yourself online if you
get it's possible to do them with any
text made theme editor and we have our
own theme format too if you need further
tweaking I particularly like this theme
that somebody made for us it's a
Christmas theme and it has a candy cane
background for your your cursor line so
that's that's pretty fun
all right so I just have a few minutes
left so let's uh let's wrap it up we did
the demo so in summary we hope that that
one to release makes it a lot more
seamless for you to work with your data
science projects that span languages and
technologies we've added a whole bunch
of quality of life improvements you can
do background jobs you can install
packages that you don't have
automatically we have custom themes
there's a whole bunch of other stuff I'm
glossing over large swathes of
improvements here and all the stuff that
you're seeing today is available in the
our studio 1.2 pre public preview which
is getting quite close to a stable
release which we expect to how about
this spring and if you if you want to
get at any of the code that I've I've
shown in this presentation I put it up
at this link it's got everything that
you need to run it all you need to do is
download the art studio 1.2 preview
which I have which I've linked at this
at this as well and you can run run all
that code yourself all the data is
included so if you'd like to play with
it and kind of get a feel for how
working working with those languages is
you are you're more than welcome to do
so
and that's all I got thank you very much
for your time
[Applause]
Thank You Jonathan
we have time for a few questions while
the next speaker is setting up just wave
me down and I'll throw this in your
direction
yeah thanks for the great talk Jonathan
for those background jobs can he launch
him on a computer besides running them
locally okay you were doing there like
any external or server server things
like that got it says the question was
and you may have been sort of hinted
into this by the fact that the that says
run local job yeah so there's a feature
in our studio server Pro that allows you
to run run these jobs anyway basically
anywhere that you're our sessions can
run if you're interested in learning
more about that there's a talk about the
our studio job launcher that will go
into a lot more detail about how you can
use the background jobs feature to
launch like much bigger jobs on your
compute cluster yeah are there any plans
to open up the languages user-created
highlighting and completions like that I
said so the question was is are we going
to basically create a system that allows
you to plug your own language engine and
start into our studios so that there's a
possibility to make user user extensible
languages but we don't currently have
plans for that but we are watching the
language server protocol project which
if Microsoft started for a Visual Studio
code that aims to provide a consistent
back-end for that kind of thing so we're
keeping an eye on it but we don't have
specific plans for right now thank you
oh wait 30 seconds I can I can answer
questions 30 seconds go ahead
hub as well or just cram packages it
only looks at crammed packages so when
you open up an our script like it you
there's really no way of telling where
the package came from so it's just it's
not looking for installation commands
it's looking for like library commands
and so because it doesn't really know
where the packages came from all it can
do is offer to install the crane
versions now that said it is also pretty
simple to to use something like packrat
in we're also working on a few other
initiatives that will make it easier for
you to a snapshot your
package dependencies and replay them on
someone else's machine so if you really
care about like installing the exact
version of the package that was work
with our script you need some other
metadata of some kind yeah but we don't
currently support those for that
particular feature
[Music]